why is Starbucks a hundred billion
dollar company well I'll tell you what
it isn't it's not because they have some
amazing funnels or some converting
landing page or some crazy ad copy it's
because their average lifetime value per
customer is over 14
000 in five dollar cup increments that's
over 2 800 cups of coffee that people
buy over the lifetime when they become
Starbucks customers and the biggest
success that Starbucks did was they
realized they needed to find a way to
create a product that people wouldn't
stop buying so until you get to the
point where people continually buy your
product over and over and over again and
tell their friends about it you should
stay at that stage because once you get
that crack then you can scale Limitless
and you only need to acquire a customer
once to keep them for life